hey youtubers it's Charlie since we're
starting to learn a lot more about the
flash TV show I thought it'd be fun to
talk about my top five favorite flash
stories and ones that obviously I hope
get turned into stories on the TV show
just to be clear though they're probably
going to spend a lot of time during
season one doing that origin story you
know helping Barry Allen find his
purpose and learn all about the Speed
Force I do think we'll see Barry Allen
as a hero in season one but I think
it'll be season two before he starts to
look like a superhero I feel like a lot
of superheroes are really selfish with
their powers whenever they first get
them you know until they get that Stan
Lee speech with great power comes great
responsibility
obviously this is the DC Universe but
all characters get a version of that
speech no matter where they come from
how awesome would it be if Jon was the
ship was alone that gave Grant Gustin
that Uncle Ben's speech even if it turns
out that he's not Jay Garrick in case
you're finding me for the first time
Wednesdays and Thursdays are usually the
days when I do DC related videos you
know like arrow and the flash Tuesdays
are gonna be my Marvel days from now on
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything it's gonna be a lot of fun so
let's get started here my top five
favorite flash stories number five the
Blitz storyline this like most of the
good flash stories in recent memory is a
Geoff Johns rewriting of the origin of
Professor zoom or just zoom in his pre
new 52 incarnation what's really cool
about the story is that John's makes
Wally West the current flash of the time
complicit in the origin of his greatest
nemesis and he ties it back all the way
to the trial of Barry Allen from the
1980s comic when he killed the second
professor zoom the professor zoom in
this story though is the third version
of the character the hunter zolomon
version on the TV series it's gonna be a
little bit different it's gonna be
Edward Thawne which is kind of a riff on
the second professor zoom character AO
Barth on number four the first return of
Barry Allen during the 1990s this story
happened in the same year that day one
killed Superman in Death of Superman and
two Bane broke Batman's spine during
nightfall so bringing Barry Allen back
from the dead almost went unnoticed the
character had been killed during crisis
on Infinite Earths and had been out of
the comics ever since then which was
about seven years the story is all about
Barry Allen rediscovering himself and
Wally West who had become the new flash
learning to share the spotlight this is
a really good comic to read if you want
to learn about the physics of the Speed
Force it's a little like Mythbusters
flash Edition and it's got this crazy
twist ending that's totally awesome
number three this one's all about the
villains rogues revenge this is an
awesome flash story that focuses on the
during the events of Final Crisis during
2008 and 2009 it picks up right after
they killed Bart Allen and gives you a
really deep cut of what it's like to be
a flash villain there are a lot like
this Suicide Squad and that they're not
crazy evil like zoom but they're not
really good people either it's totally
possible that they could do a story like
this in one or two episodes you know -
the details of Final Crisis just a
villain centric arc for an entire
episode it'd be just like arrow doing an
episode that followed mostly Slade
instead of Oliver number two flashpoint
the end of Geoff Johns this was the last
flash title that Geoff Johns wrote in
the last flash book before the new 52
reboot the story can be kind of hard to
follow if you're new to the idea of how
time paradoxes work but essentially zoom
changes the past creating a new timeline
and Barry Allen fixes it but in the
process makes himself a living paradox
essentially erasing himself from
existence the solution of the problem
though is really ingenious because they
use it to explain how in real life the
DC vertigo and Wildstorm comic book
universes now exists together in the new
52 reboot so it solved this huge problem
that DC had they had all these different
characters and their different imprints
and they needed a way to bring them all
together just like Marvel brought their
characters together and my number one
favorite flash story no surprise here
rebirth so rewind to the beginning this
story is actually the start of Geoff
Johns second run on the flash with Ethan
Van Sciver they had just rebooted Green
Lantern and done the Sinestro Corps war
which by the way is amazing the story is
all about the second return of Barry
Allen after the events of Final Crisis
and includes characters from all over
the Flash's 70 year comic book history
it also treats the different types of
powers each version of the flash has in
very interesting ways you know for
instance Jay Garrick SuperSpeed is
different from the way Barry Allen and
Wally West are affected by the Speed
Force
so rebirth kind of reimagines the shared
flash universe so since then the flash
has been rebooted again for the new 52
universe so there are a ton of other
flash stories I mean it's been going on
for almost 70 years now but I considered
these five to be the best you really
can't go wrong with Geoff Johns he's
actually doing justice league right now
but now it's your turn let me know below
in the comments what is your favorite
flash story and do you think they're
gonna do a lot of comic book based
stories during season one of the TV show
or are they going to try and do their
own thing so like I said earlier Tuesday
is gonna be my new big Marvel day and
Wednesday is gonna be big arrow day
be sure to subscribe to get everything
I'm also working on a big Captain
America 3 video for tomorrow right now
you can click here to get my first
preview for the flash TV show and you
can click here to learn all about arrow
season 3 thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you